you're gonna love it  it's just peace and relaxation and  relentless pounding for like six days  don't forget about the beer  Wow place is amazing  sometimes you've known someone a really  long time you just wanna kiss just see  if they're a good kisser that once  there's anything wrong with that  oh boy that's how people get yourselves  shot it looks like you guys were having  some kind of party last night  she's sick I'm not huh my god are we  lucky differently  no any one of you could have it then  kids got diseased cattle gets sick you  gotta kill it before it spreads the rest  of her are you going to get help  I don't wanna get sick I don't want any  of us to get sick  I'm not looking so good I don't look so  good  we're all gonna get it we're all gonna  get  you  and